[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the youtube algorithm
really notices me
shenla's remembrance of earth's past
trilogy describes the journey of mankind
through eight distinct eras
the common era the era most familiar to
the one you and i know before they knew
what awaited within the dark forest
beyond the stars
the year 201 x ce or 2010 ad would mark
the end of the common era the epoxy e
stood for crisis era
this was the era directly following
humanity's discovery that not only was
there other intelligent life in the
universe but it was vicious and hungry
determined to snuff out the human race
and claim the earth for its own
the crisis era would last from 201 x ce
to 2208 a.d
which would mark the start of the
deterrence era which would last 62 years
to be followed by a brief period of time
known as the post-deterrence era which
lasted approximately two years from 2270
to 2272.
the aegis that followed were in order
the broadcast era from 2272 to 2332
the bunker era from 2333 to 2400
the galaxy era which began in 2273
and continued indefinitely
and finally the black domain era for the
dx3906 star system which lasted from
2687 through 18906
4116 we will discuss all of these errors
in future videos but in this one we will
hone in on perhaps the most crucial era
of all for humanity
the deterrence era
which begin with the wall facer known as
lulu g
part one
the wall facers
to understand what happened to bring
about the deterrence era which kept the
tricelerians at bay after the
devastating droplet attack which
annihilated humanity's entire space
force we have to talk about the wall
facers
the wall facer project was enacted in
year seven of the crisis era
it was known that the tricelerians
through the powers of their technology
had the ability to monitor the actions
of humanity in real time
this was by use of a supercomputer
etched onto a proton this supercomputer
was entangled at the quantum level with
another on the world of trisolaris
the word quantum of course refers to the
minimum unit of any physical entity
involved in interaction
quantum entanglement also sometimes
referred to as the quantum non-local
connection is a property of a quantum
mechanical system in which the quantum
states of two objects are linked
together in such a way that one object
can no longer be adequately described
without full mention of its counterpart
this gave the aliens perfect sight of
all events on earth and the ability to
instantly sabotage much of the
technological progress at the quantum
level
the trisolarens did have blind spots
however
because of the nature of their own
existence the tricelerians did not have
a full grasp of human deception
they also had no access to the inner
workings of the human mind
they could not read human thoughts they
could not easily interpret human
emotions the wall facer project was
meant to take advantage of these facts
four wall facers were chosen the first
was the american citizen frederick tyler
a former secretary of defense
the second was a man named manuel ray
diaz the current president of venezuela
the third was a world-renowned english
scientist and politician named bill
hines
the fourth and seemingly least qualified
wall facer was a chinese man named luogi
the wall facers from within their own
minds were to each devise a plan to
thwart the tricelerians
they would have diplomatic immunity
globally and unlimited resources to go
about their efforts
at its heart the project consists of
selecting a group of people to formulate
and direct strategic plans
they will develop their plans entirely
in their own minds with no communication
of any kind with the outside world
the true strategy of these plans the
necessary steps for completion and the
ultimate aims will remain hidden inside
the brain we shall call them the wall
facers because that ancient easter name
for meditators mirrors the unique
characteristics of their work
as they direct the execution of their
strategic plans the thoughts and
behaviors these wall facers present to
the outside world will be entirely false
a carefully crafted melange of disguise
misdirection and deception
the subject of this misdirection and
deception will be the entire world both
enemy and ally until a huge bewildering
maze of illusions is erected to make the
enemy lose its judgment and to delay as
long as possible the moment it works out
our true strategic intent
the wall faces would be granted
unprecedented powers that would allow
them if they so chose to mobilize and
exploit earth's military resources they
would not be expected to explain their
commands or their actions regardless of
how discombobulating their behavior
might appear to the outside the sole
organization granted the authority to
veto wall facer commands would be the
u.n planetary defense council
who would also monitor and control wall
phaser activity
the wall facers would use hibernation
technology in order to bridge the
centuries until the time came when
humanity would face the tricelerians
waking when it was necessary to engage
another stage of their plan
the wall facers are undertaking the most
difficult mission in human history
they will truly be on their own
their souls closed off to the world to
the entire universe
their only communication partner and
sole spiritual support will be
themselves shouldering this great
responsibility they will pass through
the long years alone
so let me speak for all humanity and
offer them our deepest respect
all four wall facers made efforts
they all failed but won
low g would ultimately be responsible
for saving the human race
part two
the spell
by chance
previously in his life luogi had come
into contact with yaowinji the woman
responsible for intentionally exposing
the location of earth to trisolaris and
founding eto earth trisolaris
organization which acted as the human
hand of the trisillerins on this planet
it was because of her that he had been
introduced to the concept of cosmic
sociology it was based on only two
axioms first
survival is the primary need of
civilization
second civilization continuously grows
and expands but the total matter in the
universe remains constant
the tricelerians were aware of the fact
that yawinji had introduced luogi to
this concept because they knew that the
ultimate extrapolation of its axioms
would lead to a piece of information
about the universe that the tricelerians
were attempting to conceal from humanity
throughout the years luigi had fixated
on yawinji's words to him trying to
extract as much meaning as possible
eventually he begins to understand
perhaps there were deadly assassins
shielded in the darkness of the cosmos
he had to test his theory and he knew
one way to do so
he called it a spell
using the sun's radio wave magnification
capabilities they would send a message
out into the cosmos
this message would contain three simple
images along with some additional
information intended to demonstrate the
images were sent by some form of
intelligence
each of the images were of planets in
the star system 187 j3x1
what is it ask the us representative who
like the rest of the attendees was
inspecting the images carefully while
face her luo g according to the basic
principles of the wall facer project you
do not need to answer that question the
chair said
it's a spell
he said
the rustling and murmuring in the
auditorium stopped abruptly everyone
looked up in the same direction so that
luigi now knew the location of the
screen displaying his feed
what as the chair with narrowed eyes
he said it's a smell
someone seated at the circular table
said loudly
a spell against whom liu g answered
against the planets of star 187 j3x1 of
course it could also work directly
against the star itself
what effect will it have that's unknown
right now but one thing is certain
the effect of the spell will be
catastrophic is there a chance these
planets have life i consult it
repeatedly with the astronomical
community on that point
from present observational data the
answer is no luigi said narrowing his
eyes like the chair had
he prayed silently may they be right
the star system 187 j3x1 was about 50
light years away so it would take at
least that long for there to be any
results to his spell
luigi instructed them to only wake him
from hibernation when the effect of his
spell had been detected
but luji's wishes would not be respected
he was not woken until approximately 200
years later and by this point in history
the wall facer project was all but
forgotten
many in the current era looked upon the
decision to form the wall facer project
in the first place has a gross
misjudgment on the part of the leaders
of the old age in this day and age luigi
would be looked at as little more than
an average citizen
it wouldn't be until after the battle of
darkness which annihilated the entirety
of earth's space force that the wall
phaser project was revalidated and
luogi's status restored
the reasons for the restoration of this
project and his status were simple
his spell had worked
187 j3 x1 has been destroyed
when
51 years ago it was observed a year ago
but no one was paying much attention to
that star so the observations were only
discovered this afternoon
a few desperate people in the sfjc
wanted to find inspiration in history
and they remembered the wall facer
project and your spell so they looked at
187 j3x1 and found that it wasn't there
anymore in its place was a nebula of
debris
they scanned through all observational
records of the star until its
destruction a year ago
then pulled all of the observational
data of 187j3x1
at the time it exploded luogi's spell
had revealed the location of the star to
the greater universe
marking it as a system bearing life
though he knew otherwise
the effect was the same
the star had been fully stable it had
not gone nova naturally
prior to its destruction a tiny object
called a photoid moving near the speed
of light was observed rushing at the
star
the resulting explosion vaporized all
four planets in the star system
luogi now understood that he was correct
he had been chosen to become a wall
facer because the tricelerins had wanted
him dead
they wanted him dead because they knew
he was close to uncovering the secret
they had desperately wanted to conceal
from humanity the universe is actively
hostile and intelligent life that
revealed itself was ultimately wiped out
by a technologically superior race
whatever civilization had destroyed 187
j3x1 was far more advanced than the
tricelerans by several orders of
magnitude
the location of earth at this point had
only been revealed to the trisolarens
the aliens knew that if humanity knew
this secret of the universe they may
attempt to reveal the location of
trisolaris which would also
inadvertently reveal the location of the
earth as well dooming both civilizations
part 3 the chain of suspicion
to understand the hostility of cosmic
society you have to understand a concept
known as chain of suspicion
the books use a metaphor of two worlds
they are the only worlds in the universe
let's call these two civilized worlds
your civilization and my civilization
they are separated by a great distance
say
a hundred light years
you can detect that i exist but you
don't know any details
however i'm completely ignorant of your
presence
now we need to define two concepts
benevolence and malice between
civilizations
these words themselves aren't very
rigorous in a scientific context
so we've got to restrict their meaning
benevolence means not taking the
initiative to attack and eradicate other
civilizations
malice is the opposite
there is no way for either of the
civilizations to know whether or not the
other is benevolent or malignant
the world that knows of the existence of
the other is at an advantage here
even if they do not know the specific
location of the other world the fact
that they know of its existence means
that they can search for them and due to
the exponential nature of technological
growth they will eventually locate them
it's only a matter of time
let's say both civilizations know of
each other's existence even if both
civilizations think the other is
benevolent neither of the civilizations
can feel safe because as i said before
there is no way for either of the
civilizations to know what the other
thinks of it
you might assume that through
communication these two worlds would be
able to determine whether the other was
malicious or not
if the other world was benevolent
communication could potentially be
continued and perhaps the worlds could
be united if not then the
technologically weaker civilization
would be eradicated this type of
scenario could happen on earth but the
chain of suspicion is much longer in
space
let's say that both civilizations know
that the other thinks that they are
benevolent they still don't know what
the other thinks about what they think
about the other
it's a convoluted line of logic that
goes on indefinitely on earth the chain
of suspicion would be resolved quickly
humans have common language common
experience
and efficient communication none of this
is present in space among separate races
of beings on separate worlds in the
cosmos
that's the chain of suspicion
it's something you don't see on earth
humanity's shared species cultural
similarities interconnected ecosystem
and close distances means that in this
environment the chain of suspicion will
only extend a level or two before it's
resolved through communication but in
space the chain of suspicion can be very
long
something like the battle of darkness
will already have taken place before
communication can resolve it
in actual cosmic civilization the
biological differences between different
groups might be as high as the kingdom
level and cultural differences are even
further beyond our imagining add this to
the vast distances between them and you
have chains of suspicion that are
practically indestructible that means
that the outcome is the same
regardless of whether we're benevolent
civilizations or malicious civilizations
that's right that's the most important
aspect of the chain of suspicion it is
unrelated to the civilization's own
morality and social structure
it is enough to think of every
civilization as the points at the end of
the chain
regardless of whether civilizations are
internally benevolent or malicious when
they enter the web formed by chains of
suspicion they're all identical
now you might think that a benevolent
civilization that knows of the existence
of a much weaker civilization could
attempt to communicate with the weaker
civilization which wouldn't be a threat
to the technologically superior world
this of course would not work because of
a concept i mentioned earlier the
exponential nature of technological
progress
humans have existed for approximately
100 000 years but the vast majority of
our technological progression has
happened within the last 300 years on
the scale of the universe whose timeline
moves on a much slower trajectory
this is not merely a progression this is
an explosion
on earth it took 300 years but there's
no reason why humanity should be the
fastest of all cosmic civilizations
maybe there are others whose
technological explosions were even more
sudden i'm weaker than you but once i've
received your message and know of your
existence the chain of suspicion is
established between us
if at any time i experience a
technological explosion that suddenly
puts me far ahead of you then i'm
stronger than you on the scale of the
universe several hundred years is a snap
of a finger and it might be that my
knowledge of your existence and the
information i received from our
communication was the perfect spark to
set off that explosion that means that
even though i'm just a newborn or
growing civilization i'm still a big
danger to you if you are the stronger
civilization the weaker civilization is
a threat because of the potential for
technological explosion they could find
and destroy your civilization within a
blip on the cosmic scale this was the
very reason the trisolarens attempted to
stall human technological progress the
tricelerins and the humans are unique in
this particular case however rather than
attempting to annihilate the world as
would be the goal of most dark forest
attacks the tricelerians seek to live on
the world themselves their own world was
a part of a triple star system causing
their planet to be highly unstable
environmentally the tricelerians had
never been able to correct this problem
and instead sought a new home
earth was perfect for them but even if
the trisolarens didn't wish to inhabit
earth themselves earth revealing its own
location would have still had
devastating consequences
the chain of suspicion is the reason
that the universe is a dark forest
part 4
the deterrence era
now that we understand the chain of
suspicion we can talk about the
deterrence era
directly following the battle of
darkness luogi discovered the results of
his spell
using the sun he was able to transmit
three images into the cosmos
each of the images consisted of 30
points which represented the planar
projection of a three-dimensional
coordinate system that contained the
position of 30 stars by combining the
three images an intelligence could
create a cubic space populated by those
30 points it would represent the
relative positions of 187 j3 x1 and the
30 or so stars surrounding it a label
also drew attention to the star 187 j3x1
think carefully about it and you'll get
it
a hunter in a dark forest stalking with
baited breath
suddenly notices that a piece of bark
has been stripped from a tree in front
of him
on the eye-catching bit of a white wood
that's been revealed is a position in
the forest written in characters that
all hunters can recognize what will he
think about that location
he's certainly not going to imagine that
someone has laid out supplies for him
there
out of all the possibilities the most
likely one is that the blaze is
informing everyone that there's live
prey at that location that needs to be
eliminated
even if the vast majority of the
civilizations that receive the message
chose not to act
at least some will
and that act due to chain of suspicion
will almost certainly be hostile
luigi realizes what he must do
as i said the tricelerians monitor all
human events
luigi had only to speak out in order to
speak to them directly
i'm speaking to trisolaris luji said his
voice wasn't loud he thought about
repeating himself but he knew that they
could hear him luji raised his left hand
revealing an object on his wrist the
size of a watch this is a vital signs
monitor linked through a transmitter to
a cradle system
you remember wallface array diaz from
two centuries ago so you certainly know
about cradle systems the signal sit from
this monitor travels the links of the
cradle system to the snow project's
3614 bombs deployed in solar orbit
now i will in a future video do a
detailed analysis of the plans of each
wall facer but for now we will stay
focused while facer ray diaz's plan to
thwart the tricelerians had failed in
the end but as we can see luogie was
able to adapt the technology for his own
purposes
the signal is sent out once every second
to maintain the bombs in a non-triggered
state
if i die the system's maintenance signal
will vanish and all of the bombs will
detonate turning the oil film
surrounding the bombs into
3614 interstellar dust clouds ringing
the sun from a distance the sun's
visible light and other high frequency
bands will appear to flicker through the
dust cloud coverage
the position of every bomb has been
precisely arranged in solar orbit so
that this flickering will generate a
signal transmitting three simple images
of the sort i sent out two centuries ago
each image an arrangement of 30 points
with one label for composition into a
three-dimensional coordinate diagram
but unlike last time the position will
contain the transmission of trisolaris
relative to its surrounding 29 stars the
sun will be a galactic lighthouse
casting that spell in the process of
course also exposing the position of the
sun and earth to receive the entire
transmission at any single point in the
galaxy will take more than a year but
there ought to be more than a few
civilizations that have the technology
to observe the sun from multiple vantage
points if that's the case they may only
need a few days or even a few hours to
obtain all the information they need
luo g threatened to reveal the location
of earth and trisolaris both worlds
would be doomed in the end but humanity
would never be subjugated by the
tricelerans the detonator invisibly tied
to his heart would ignite revealing the
location of both worlds if he was killed
after revealing this information to the
tricelerians he then prepares for what
could be his final act
he placed the tip of the pistol to his
heart and said
now i'm going to stop the beating of my
heart
by doing so i will be committing the
greatest crime in the history of our two
worlds
i express my deepest apologies to our
two civilizations for the crime that i
commit but i have no regrets
because this is the only option
i know the sofons are nearby but you
have ignored humanity's call
silence is the greatest form of contempt
and we have put up with this contempt
for two centuries
now if you wish you can continue to
remain silent
i will give you thirty seconds
suddenly leoge saw three spheres appear
before him it was a sofon a tri-soleran
supercomputer the three spheres each
flashed a single word
stop
can i discuss terms luigi asked looking
up at the three spheres
first put down the gun then we can
discuss terms
this is not a negotiation these are my
demands if i am to go on living all i
wish to know is whether or not you
accept
state your demands
have the droplet or rather the probe
sees its transmissions towards the sun
it has been done as you ask
once the tricelerians realized the
severity of the issue they knew that
luogi had checkmated them they had no
choice but to give into his demands
otherwise risk the destruction of their
own world and the destruction of the
world they had hoped to inhabit
luluji commands the trisolares to turn
the other nine droplets heading for the
solar system away
the tricelerins immediately react
affirmatively
the probes emit visible light so that
humanity has the means to confirm that
they are in fact moving away from the
solar system
finally luo g will not permit the
trisalleran fleet to cross the oort
cloud
the trisolaris placed their ships at
maximum deceleration but informed luigi
that it will be impossible for them to
decelerate quickly enough to avoid
reaching the oort cloud luigi commands
them to set course away from the solar
system then like the droplet group set a
course away from the solar system
changing course in any direction is
death this will cause the fleet to fly
by the solar system and into the
desolation of space
the fleet's life support system will not
last long enough to return to trisolaris
or search for another viable star system
death isn't a certainty perhaps human or
triceleran ships can catch up and rescue
them this will require a command from
the high council if changing course is a
lengthy process get started on it now
that will give me and all the other
lives a chance to live on the period of
silence lasted for three minutes then
the fleet will begin to change course in
10 earth minutes two years from now
human space observation systems will be
able to observe the change of heading
the tricelerians admit that strategy had
been their ultimate failure and they had
been unable to correctly interpret lulu
g's actions during the time in which he
prepared his plan
by this point in history eto who had
once enacted their own wall breaker
program to oppose the wall facers were
no longer around
you spent two whole months in the
control room remotely controlling the
ion engines to make fine adjustments to
their positioning we didn't care about
that at the time because we thought you
were just using the meaningless task as
a way to escape reality we never
imagined what the distance between the
bombs really meant another chance was
when i consulted a group of physicists
with questions about sofon unfoldings in
space
if the eto was still around they would
have already seen through me
yes abandoning them was a mistake
the sofon vanishes and the deterrence
era begins it would last for more than
60 years and its fall would mark the
darkest point in human history yet
[Music]
following humanity's discovery of the
dark forest state of the universe
humankind finally let go of the
optimistic child it once been
humanity grew paranoid a loner in the
vast universe terrified of even a spark
from the darkness
initially even cell phone use was banned
antennas around the world were forcibly
shut down
some sense was gradually restored as
people realized that there was little
harm in the vast majority of
communications
still there were severe restrictions
regarding electromagnetic radiation and
all radio communications were required
to operate at minimum power
though most understood that these
regulations were meaningless
at the start of the deterrence era most
of earth's heavy industries moved into
orbit as a result the natural ecology of
earth recovered to what it had been
before the great ravine
in fact due to a drop in population and
the continued industrialization of food
production much of earth's land was
allowed to return to nature
almost as if the planet itself was
transforming into a giant park
g's creation of dark forest deterrence
against the tricelerians was considered
to be a great achievement but the wall
facer project itself was judged by
history as a ridiculous and childish act
lil g eventually transferred control of
the deterrent system over to the u.n and
the solar fleet and people begin to turn
their attention to deterrence itself
and from this deterrence game theory was
developed
when the deterrent was the complete
destruction of both the deterrer and the
deteree as it was in this situation then
the system was said to be in a state of
what they called ultimate deterrence
ultimate deterrence is of course
distinguished from other forms of
deterrence by the fact that carrying out
the threat would be of no benefit to the
deterrer earth in this case
the ultimate key to the turrets is the
belief by the deterree aka the
trisalarans that the deter r humanity
would almost certainly carry out the
threat
but the simple fact is if authority to
carry out the threat in dark forest
deterrence was given to all of humanity
then the probability of the threat
actually being carried out would be
practically zero asking humanity to take
action that would destroy two worlds is
difficult the decision would violate
deeply held moral principles and values
the particular conditions of dark forest
deterrence made the task even harder
should deterrence fail humanity would
survive for at least one more generation
in a sense everyone alive would be
unaffected but in the event of
deterrence failing carrying out the
threat and broadcasting would mean that
destruction could come at any moment a
far worse result than not carrying out
the threat thus if deterrence failed the
reaction of humankind as a whole could
be easily predicted when developing
deterrence game theory humanity quickly
realized that though humanity as a whole
could be predicted
individual reactions could not be so
easily predicted
the success of dark forest deterrence
was founded on the unpredictability of
luo g as an individual
if deterrence failed his actions would
be guided by his own personality and
psychology even if he acted rationally
his own interests might not match
humanity's interests perfectly
at the beginning of the deterrence era
both worlds carefully analyzed luo g's
personality and built up detailed
mathematical models human and
tricelerian deterrence game theorist
reached remarkably similar conclusions
depending on his mental state at the
moment deterrence failed lulgy's degree
of deterrence hovered between
91.9 percent and 98.4 percent
try solaris would not gamble with such
odds quite soon after humanity realized
this full control of the deterrent
system was handed back over to lugi
the entire process of transferring
authority took about 18 hours the
tricelaren's failure to take this
opportunity to destroy the ring of
nuclear bombs surrounding the sun during
this time was considered their greatest
strategic blunder during the war between
the two worlds
for the vast majority of the deterrence
era the detonation switch which would
fulfill the threat of the turns would be
kept by luogi the first sword holder in
human history it would be the second
sword holder shanxin whose inaction
would lead to the end of the deterrence
era and ultimately the destruction of
the solar system itself
we will discuss xiangzin and the events
following the deterrence era in another
video
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas
[Music]